foreign
article here we were going to read it
last week as part of the Clutter core
episode you want to go back and listen
to that by the way this podcast is
serialized so you have to listen to
every episode in sequential order
otherwise you're going to have no idea
what's going on that's right there's
there's going to be plot holes
everywhere
the color core episode we did last week
was one of my favorite episodes you've
ever done because I thought it exposed
something and allowed the three of us me
and Ryan and TK to talk about and maybe
even disagree in a way that we found
Common Ground amid our Venn diagrams
this is an article from The New York
Times it's a guest essay called clutter
is good for you
let's see if we agree with Rob Walker on
this all right several years before she
died my mother began sending me things
ostensibly significant objects these
included expected items like jewelry and
photographs and also puzzling ones for
example one afternoon I opened a package
containing a carefully wrapped eight
inch tall ceramic leprechaun that I
don't recall ever having seen my family
has no connection to Ireland
not long after she announced that she
wanted to send along her collection of
bird figurines in which I had never
expressed any special interests
found familiar listeners okay clearly
this was no longer about handing down
heirlooms it was about getting rid of
objects basically a form of decluttering
I had to put a stop to it and not just
because these objects didn't actually
mean anything to me much more important
they did mean something to her in fact
what I most enjoyed about her
accumulation of bird figurines and
Ceramics and sand dollars from Texas
beaches was her enjoyment of these
things her unself-conscious confidence
about what she liked was one of her most
admirable traits
so I persuaded her not to only keep her
figurines but also to let herself
continue to appreciate their presence
because ultimately my mother's urge to
purge struck me as Illuminating
something misguided about our general
relationship to material culture in
short what we often dismiss as quote
clutter all those non-essential often
Oddball objects that a third party
Observer might write off as needless
junk and actually be good for us
the villainization of clutter has
perhaps been most insistently pushed by
the tidying up Guru Marie kondo its
latest iteration pairs a yearning to
neaten up pandemic cocoons crowded with
stuff thanks to a couple of years of
online shopping as a monotony fighting
tactic with a trendy take on minimalism
that equates the blank space aesthetic
with mindful sophistication but the
underlying Vibe is a suspiciously
familiar one yet again minimalist scolds
insist that we should repent of our
materialist ways things they're forever
lecturing just aren't that important
bit of a straw man argument it seems to
me Ryan oh yeah yeah well you know
um I think
uh I think articles like this are
usually a straw man argument and people
are allowed to present their opinions
and arguments however they want I mean I
I think it's a shame that they would say
that uh you know minimalists are asking
people to repent
of their things right and we're
prescribing getting rid of your things
to make you happy as though it is a
means to an end yes it's the opposite it
is clearing the things that are not
important and I think where he was
absolutely right in this article is
those bird finger figurines are not
important to him right so he shouldn't
be the bearer of the figurines but I do
agree I wouldn't convince my mom to not
get rid of them no or make her feel bad
right I love her any less that she
didn't get rid of them but you can bring
up to her that hey you get immense Joy
from these things you can simply ask a
question why let go of something that
you get immense Joy from now she might
say well I'm gonna let go of them
because I'm making space for something I
get even more joy from okay that's
wonderful but asking the question as
opposed to you should keep them or you
should get rid of them that's not what
minimalism is about when we're talking
about minimalism when we talk about
minimalism men minimalism is the thing
that gets us past the things so we can
make room for life's most important
things and if those things are bird
figurines or sand dollars from a Texas
beach then so be it if they amplify your
life enhance your life who am I to tell
you to get rid of it no way in fact I'm
gonna say if it enhances your life hold
on to it until it doesn't anymore
however hold on to it Loosely be willing
to let go of it because if you're
willing to let go that means you're
holding on to it for the reasons that
you want to hold on to it you're
actually
experiencing something with that thing
as opposed to it getting in the way
because it's only clutter if it gets in
the way did you enjoy this Standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalists
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click click the link in
the description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free